13.6 billion years ago the dark scaffold
that supports all the regular matter in
the universe emerges
ablaze with stars
but how did this stellar array evolve
into a structure littered with organized
galaxies
it seems they formed under constant
threat
of destruction
october 2020
astronomers discover a monster lurking
among the cosmic web's earliest
structures
dating to 900 million years after the
big bang
a supermassive black hole
galaxies surround this cosmic giant
caught in its grip seemingly linked to
the supermassive black hole by filaments
of the developing cosmic web
it's like the universe has given
supermassive black holes an umbilical
cord
it's like an all you can eat buffet
right there
supermassive black holes
are hungry beasts they feast on any
matter that gets too close to them
supermassive black holes are likely some
of the most powerful objects in the
universe they can be anywhere between
100 000 to 10 billion times the mass of
the sun
supermassive black holes have been a
nemesis for generations of scientists
not because of their fearsome nature but
because
nobody knows how they grew so large so
early
i wish i knew where supermassive black
holes came from if i knew i would have a
nobel prize hanging around my neck and i
would wear it every single day
as someone who
deeply loves supermassive black holes
whose career is based on studying
supermassive black holes
it is very frustrating to not know where
they come from
regular stellar black holes are the
collapsed cores of dead stars ranging
from three to thousands of solar masses
but supermassive black holes
those are a different beast
13 billion years ago not enough stars
had lived and died to build something as
huge as a supermassive black hole
now the cosmic web offers scientists
clues about the black hole conundrum
we now know supermassive black holes
grow among the lattice of the young
cosmic web
gorging on the hydrogen gas that travels
along the filaments
at the same time when the cosmic web is
lighting up supermassive black holes
appear to be stealing star fuel from the
young universe
you might think that would kill a
growing galaxy
and yet most mature galaxies
have a supermassive black hole
they really dominate the physics of what
happens in the centers of galaxies and
even how galaxies can evolve
we think these galactic monsters have
been around from the start
how then did the web's young galaxies
develop around supermassive black holes
the milky way's supermassive black hole
is called sagittarius a-star it's around
27 million miles wide and weighs in at
just over 4 million solar masses
the environment around sagittarius a
star is very dynamic it can actually be
a really hellish place there's this
accretion disk that's full of plasma is
heated to thousands of degrees
so you wouldn't necessarily think that
that's a great place for star formation
to happen
but that's exactly where astronomers
decided to look
using the atacama large millimeter array
or alma for short scientists scanned the
heart of the milky way for dense cores
of gas and dust
stellar embryos
they found more than 800 within just a
thousand light years of sagittarius
a-star
including more than 40 embryos with
energetic jets blasting from their cores
the telltale sign of the birth of stars
[Music]
it's really surprising to find those
stars there it's like hearing babies
cries from a wolf's den
it's not the place you would expect this
to happen but in fact
stars are forming there now it's not as
efficient as it is out here in the
suburbs where things are quieter but it
works
baby stars igniting and thriving around
a supermassive black hole
the kind of hostile environment we know
existed in the young cosmic web
starbirth is a key part of kickstarting
young galaxies
this evidence suggests that star
formation is more resilient than
researchers thought
and they've developed a theory to
explain it
gas and dust race around the black hole
in the accretion disk
heated to incredible temperatures plumes
of gas break off and blast into space
the gas rapidly cools collapses and
forms baby stars
these accretion disks are the most
chaotic of stellar nurseries
you see this mechanism that you think is
a violently inhibiting star formation
and at the same time it's triggering the
birth of new stars
matter clumps at the cosmic web's
intersections feeding the supermassive
black holes
around them stars burst into life
slowly building galaxies
this could be how our own milky way
formed among the filaments of the young
cosmic web
but new research suggests that growth in
these baby galaxies requires murder and
mayhem and without then
we wouldn't exist
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you